you have a different way of cursing in
in Britain I mean I'm always fascinated
with the British diction but the very
swear words that we yes there are more
polite you know way of cursing I think
in England that's suitable for all hours
of the day you mean you are you have a
way of swearing in England it's less
offensive than the swears that we use do
you think I just think they don't need
to be bleeped out you know I think you
can get away in England with just
putting oh and then in any noun after it
and it somehow
you know makes you a wraps is a common
Oh rats
you know like Oh dandelion you know you
can no I don't think around saying oh
bicycles you know I mean is that
something I just said that would that
mean anything I carried it up the
knickers yeah why not you know you just
throw them all together and use the
precision accident people assume that
you're swearing that's can't be true I
have seen many British they have some I
mean bollocks that's is that that's a
nasty word in in bran ox bollocks
yes in fact the very first job I did
when I was when I was younger I was I
think I was like 5 or 6 and we were
sitting at the read-through and the word
bollocks was there but I I guess was had
never been exposed to it right I mean I
had them but you know I wasn't exposed
to the word itself and said bollocks
yeah and so the actor afterwards said Oh
bollocks to you too kid any told me you
got it wrong you were like Oh dandelion
does I've always had a theory that
American actors have a great deal of
difficulty doing a proper English accent
but I do think that the English actors
do a much better job of doing an
American accent which must be difficult
you do a very good American accent well
thank you yeah I try and I guess I try
and stay in it as much as possible on
set but it doesn't muse me the way that
Americans will always I guess it's the
sort of America first
attitude you bet it is pal saying losing
your accent they call it a compliment
Brits on being able to lose their
accents is this American standard
American accent was the accent yes yes
lose you lose yours to get me to the the
real American version yeah exactly
yeah that's uh yeah that's you started
over with us I mean you know let's we
went over and well I was in Ireland and
that wasn't going so well so we left and
it's still not going so well no it is it
is fascinating that that the I must you
must really hurt your rear when American
actors do the the British accent and get
it wrong you're being polite but i yeah
i know that i worked with Hugh Laurie on
something wants when he was on house and
I got to shoot a scene with him and he
had such a convincing American accent
that I'd startled me when he after we
were done came up and talked to me and
had delightful British accent and he's
so good we all know he will or a house
we don't think of him but he actually
had the entire crew around him they
would all speak an American accents and
he liked that because it helped him keep
his American accent but he had one guy
in his crew who was British and in
between takes would say things in a
British accent and Hugh Laurie couldn't
stand it because he would be like you're
making me revert yeah
back to kippers and pitbulls and doubles
and you know dandelions yeah I just I
just reduced your whole language to mush
right there I apologize sorry not you
know yeah fair enough yeah America first
you are here after all
you